so as women leaders we take we tend to
make take our uh masculine energy
into our relationships and that's what
repels a man especially a man that is a
masculine man a man that's looking for
something serious and for a commitment
and you know to get married and
eventually have what do you mean
masculine energy you're taking masculine
energy into a relationship that repels a
man break that yeah because
no man wants to com wants his girl to to
to feel like a man him her you know for
her to feel like a man yeah so you don't
want to be in a relationship with a man
you want to be in a relationship with
this beautiful feminine goddess energy
woman
right a lot of women who are in uh
powerful positions um and even women who
are not in powerful positions they don't
they don't learn about emotional
intelligence they don't learn about you
know uh staying in their lane staying in
their feminine energy allowing the man
to be the hunter allowing the man to
show up as the man right and if a man
doesn't show up then why would he want
to be with him stop trying to force
things or for him to try to do stuff
you know
so i think it's extremely important to
learn about um
feminine energy and masculinity can you
give an example of what
bringing
masculine energy into the relationship
is
so for example um
you know
a woman comes home hey babe um i want to
do this i want to do that let's go to
dinner i picked the restaurant i picked
this up like that right she did
everything
give the man the chance to do that for
you lean back majority of the women
don't lean back and if they don't hear
from if they don't hear from him they're
chasing and and texting him hey what's
going on hey are we going on a date
tonight no you're so busy with your life
it's so full and complete
that your man is going to come after you
because he respects you more the fact
that you're not
all over him all the time you know so so
a lot of women want to do the work and
that's when they lose the man that's
when you know uh all of a sudden he
loses attraction for her and they don't
understand why but that's that's the
reason why but isn't a woman supposed to
i mean
take care of like oh when when babe
comes home like we're going to eat this
or we're going to take care of this a
woman's not really supposed to do not
supposed to but isn't that something
also like men kind of like you know they
talk about like a housewife a house why
have you come home she has to earn it
there better be a ring on that finger
before she starts doing that amen
okay so victoria you're you're over here
like amen and jesus over here i know
what did melissa say or what did natalya
say that you agreed with or that you
disagreed with i mean he's got to earn
it like earn what sorry
you can open up your cold ravioli if i'm
not your girlfriend or
if i'm not your wife like i'm sorry i'm
not gonna go home and cook for you and
go like make your bed clean your home do
all these things for you if there's no
commitment mm-hmm i mean it's the truth
and i see that in a lot of my friends
they like do all these things for guys
that barely committed to them and then
they wonder why like what happened like
they just expected it they expected hey
i don't have to commit to this woman if
she's doing all this stuff to me and i
can go flirt with other girls go on
dates with other girls i don't have to
fully commit to her and she's still like
coming home cooking me dinner doing all
these sweet things like your advice to
women is pump the brakes a little bit
don't just start cooking cleaning being
a great housewife
before there's a commitment before
there's a ring on the finger
exactly okay you have a ring on the
finger does your
your business and your career
change
i'm sorry like say you have the ring on
the finger right and you do cook at home
and stuff like that
now because that is now like your
priority does your business now take a
hit absolutely not okay you stay 100
committed to that
that's your second marriage you know
what i mean because you put work then
your husband then well no you keep them
both you know okay in their lane you
know not that one comes before the other
right but you don't stop doing uh your
work so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire sauscast click
right here
[Music]